speaking of outrageous
folks this cannot be right this can't
possibly be it is
a trump advisor
lawyer who was involved in the effort to
try to change the election results by
pressuring brad raffensberger in georgia
she has now been appointed to a federal
election panel
it is what it is
trump adviser appointed to panel on u.s
elections writes the associated press
the u.s commission on civil rights has
appointed to a federal election advisory
board a prominent republican attorney
who assisted trump in his failed effort
to overturn the 2020 election results
cleeda mitchell is cleta the female
version of cletus i've never heard that
name before cleta mitchell
was named to the board of advisors for
the federal election assistance
commission
the advisory board does not have the
ability to directly make policy but can
recommend voluntary guidelines the eac
certifies voting systems and advises
local election office on offices on
compliance with federal election
regulations
mitchell was nominated by the republican
appointed members on the commission and
approved by a majority vote mitchell is
a prominent republican lawyer who joined
trump on a january second phone call
with georgia secretary of state brad
raffensberger on the call trump implored
raffensberger to find him enough votes
for him to be declared the winner
remember that guys i need 11 000 votes
give me a break exactly
um
which was won by biden mitchell claimed
she found possible examples of fraud in
the state but the secretary of state's
office told her her data was incorrect
she says i'm honored to have been
selected with bipartisan support that's
true at least one democrat did vote for
her uh to be given this position
guys it's uh i mean listen
is this should this be illegal no
is she necessarily going to do something
wrong in this position no i guess not
but the optics of this are absurd she
was on the phone with brad raffensberger
saying we found fraud you got to review
the results and now she's going to be on
a panel
that advises
election offices
on voting systems and preventing fraud
it's i don't even know that i can call
it a grift is it just the incestuous
nature of american politics
is it a grift is it
is it something else i don't know
but it's very very depressing